this episode is brought to you by ground
news the world's first
ever news comparison platform anybody
who consumes the news these days knows
that it's an imperfect system
though kidding gone are the days of
quiet passionate journalists who tell it
like it is in today's increasingly loud
news environment is harder than ever
to tell sense from nonsense thankfully
there's ground news a helpful app
designed by media outsiders that is
dedicated to fighting misinformation
abbas news coverage tired of one-sided
news coverage while cut through the bias
in the bs using ground news's popular
aggregate feed which pulls together
stories from more than 50 000 sources
all across the ideological spectrum
ground news allows you to filter news by
political leaning so
you can jump into the app and see the
same story brought to you by a left-wing
ascender or a right-wing news source
oftentimes you might see a story that is
sensationalized by the left or might be
overblown by the right
either way having the ability to see the
entire news ecosystem in one place has
brilliant contextual ability
that you didn't even know you needed
granules also has a popular feature
called news blind spot that
readers from across the political
spectrum like ever wonder if you're
missing a story because it's not showing
up in your own little
political echo chamber well you're not
going to miss it with ground news
because it doesn't just show stories
from multiple perspectives it shows you
which ideological
groups are covering or ignoring certain
stories learn more and try it for
yourself by downloading the free
ground news app or clicking the link in
the description below and let's get into
the video
during frank costello's trial as lawyers
advised him that he should stop dressing
in expensive suits that cost hundreds of
dollars
and instead wear more regular stuff off
the rack to make himself look more
relatable
he replied i'm sorry counselor but i'd
rather blow the goddamn case that's the
kind of man frank costello was
he was always careful to look his best
and he liked to spend his time with
a better class of people for some
mobsters this meant rubbing elbows with
movie stars and
other hollywood big shots the castello
this meant the world of politics
it has been said that no other crime
boss had more politicians and judges in
their pocket
costello saw them as an invaluable
resource so we always made sure to do
them favors
raise money for their campaigns and
increase their voter turnout
of course in return they all owed him
and costello always intended to collect
at the most opportune time
due to his ever-growing spider web of
political connections
frank costello has been nicknamed the
prime minister of the underworld
and today we will take a look at his
criminal career from his beginnings as a
petty thief
to his rise as boss of the most powerful
family in the mafia
to his violent downfall
frank costello was born francesco
castiglia on january 26 1891 in a tiny
hamlet called laura poli
in the italian region of calabria he was
the youngest child of luigi and maria
castiglia who
also had an older son and four daughters
as prospects weren't looking too good
for the family and calabria luigi
decided to do the same thing as
countless other italians in 1895 he
took some of his older children and
traveled to america in search of a
better
life planning to send for the rest of
his family once he was settled
just a few months later maria castiglia
sold everything she owned in
calabria and boarded a ship for new york
accompanied by her youngest offspring
including the four-year-old francesco
the family lived in east
harlem in an area that was known back
then as little italy due to its large
population of italian immigrants
although
we should mention that it is not the
same as the little italy of today luigi
worked as a laborer while maria opened a
store selling
traditional italian products back then
the national crime syndicate was still a
long way away but local crime bosses
still existed
who mainly controlled the rackets within
an individual neighborhood
frank costello's first experience with
the criminal underworld may have been a
woman
named pascarella spinelli she operated a
horse stable near where the castellos
lived but she mainly used it as a front
for buying and selling stolen horses
an urban myth also said that she allowed
other criminals to bury their victims on
her property
which is why the place became known as
the murder stable in local
law there's nothing to suggest that
young frank ever worked for her
just that he witnessed a lot of the
dealings that went on in there costello
himself turned to crime when he was just
a teenager
starting out small with petty theft he
first got into trouble with the law in
1908 when he was arrested trying to
extort a local merchant but the charges
were dismissed he was then arrested in
1912 but again
faced no serious consequences it wasn't
until 1915 that costello's luck finally
ran out and the 24 year old served
almost a year in prison for carrying a
concealed gun from that point on
costello rarely carried a weapon on him
over the decades he would develop a
reputation of being a relatively
amicable man at least in his line of
work and
it is uncertain if he ever actually
killed anyone costello preferred to
achieve his goals through corruption and
influence but it would be
a rather generous stretch to call him
peaceful he was still involved one way
or another in numerous vile and
acts if he truly never got his hands
dirty that was only because he was
surrounded by others
who would do it for him
anyway we're getting a bit ahead of
ourselves for now frank costello was
still just a petty criminal in his early
twenties he was working for a gang led
by a man named morello
and that was when he met his future
partners who would help him
revolutionize organize crime in america
they were lucky luciano and
mayor lansky the arrival of prohibition
was a giant boon for all criminals in
america
like many others costello became
involved in bootlegging although he ran
other rackets such as gambling and
extortion on the side
already costello was displaying his
predilection for building contacts and
relationships with the people on the
other side of the law so
while his partners were busy handling
their operations costello's main
responsibility was
greasing all the right palms to make
sure that everyone was paid
and happy their biggest problems came
from some of their bosses who were stuck
in the old ways of doing things
equilibrians didn't think costello
should be doing business with a sicilian
like
luciano or vice versa let alone both of
them working with the jewish and irish
gangs in the late 1920s the formation of
the national crimes indicate helped
smooth over somewhat the working
relationships between the multi-ethnic
criminal organizations
but the american mafia was still in
turmoil due to several people vying for
the position of kappa de tuticappi
the boss of all bosses this was resolved
in 1931 during the castel-morezi war a
pivotal moment in american crime history
that led to the formation of the
commission now we've already talked
about the casamaresi war
in detail in our buyer's mayor landscape
buxy siegel since
their gang members were used as hitmen
to take out the former bosses if you
haven't seen those videos maybe give
them a watch but well here's the cliff
notes version
two bosses joe masseria and salvatore
maranzano were fighting to become the
boss of all bosses they were both
betrayed by costello luciano and
the rest of the younger mobsters who
wanted a more modern and equitable way
of handling things instead of always
having one man at the top
first messeria was killed then maranzano
a few months later
afterwards lucky luciano and all the
other important mobsters held a meeting
where they formed the commission a
ruling body that oversaw
all mafia activities in the country and
mediated conflicts the commission had a
board of directors which consisted of
the seven most powerful italian families
in the country the five new york
families plus the buffalo crime family
and the chicago outfit run by al capone
all the other ones were represented in
the commission by one of the seven
acting as their intermediary
unsurprisingly the luciano crime family
was
their biggest and most powerful of all
it was run by lucky luciano himself
obviously while a man named vito
genovese served as underboss and his
trusted ally frank costello was his new
[Music]
consigliere
during his time as consigliere costello
ran multiple rackets that turned him
into one of the mafia's best earners but
none were more profitable than his slot
machine business
at its peak he had around 25 000
machines in new york and its surrounding
state
technically they were classified as
candy machines since they would dispense
a mint on
a losing pool it was a good grift but it
only lasted for a couple of years
in 1934 florella laguardia was elected
as the new mayor of new york city on an
anti-corruption platform and he declared
war on slot machines by
literally having them smashed bits and
thrown into the long island sound it was
a heavy blow for costello but he made up
for it somewhat by securing a new deal
to
bring the slot machines to louisiana a
much bigger blow for costello and the
whole family came in 1936 when lucky
luciano was convicted of running a
prostitution ring
and sentenced to 30 to 50 years in
prison his underboss vito genovese
became the acting boss but
just a year later he had to flee to
italy to avoid a murder indictment
therefore frank costello was now head of
the luciano crime family
even though lucky still gave orders from
behind bars this arrangement worked for
a while costello was involved in a lot
of different rackets with other mobsters
mainly in gambling and bookmaking
operations with
the likes of mayor lansky bugsy siegel
and tony acado he proved to be
invaluable as a partner in such
businesses due to his ever-growing
network of political connections it has
often been said
though not definitively proven that
costello even had jay edgar hoover in
his pocket which was why hoover denied
the existence of mafia for decades how
exactly costello achieved this is
still a juicy bit of mafia law hoover
liked to bet on horses although he
always claimed he never put down more
than two dollars on a single race
however according to rumors costello
would give him tips on fixed races and
hoover would use
agents to place large bets on his behalf
that is the most common version of the
story although a much more salacious
rumor stated that costello and
mayolansky had incriminating photographs
of hoover engaged in homosexual activity
on the inside luciano was still hopeful
for an early release and his opportunity
presented itself when the united states
ended world war ii in february 1942 the
airset normandy caught fire and
capsized while docked at new york's pier
88. the government feared that this
could have been the results of sabotage
by nazi spies or sympathizers so they
developed one of their more
outlandish world war ii initiatives
dubbed operation underworld it was an
uneasy alliance with the mafia in order
to
keep the docks safe limit black market
theft of valuable resources
and prevent labor strikes luciano went
along with the whole thing in exchange
for early release but
things did not go exactly as he planned
he got out of prison in 1946 but the u.s
government deported him back to italy
for castello things stayed more or less
the same during the war he was still the
acting boss of the luchana crime family
while his cousin willie moretti served
as his underboss but his life was about
to become a lot more complicated and
dangerous as he faced two new threats
both from the government and from inside
the mafia
lucian and costello always managed to
maintain an amicable relationship but
the same could not be said for the third
man at the top of their crime family
hierarchy
veto genovese as we previously mentioned
genovese briefly became the new head of
the family when luciano went to jail but
he then had to flee to italy during the
war genovese befriended the fascists in
order to make his life easier allegedly
even orchestrating a few hits in america
on their behalf when the tide turned
genovese switched sides but things
did not work out so well this time he
was arrested by the us military police
in italy for running a smuggling ring
and
then it was discovered that he was a
fugitive wanted for murder in america in
1945 genovese was sent back to new york
to stand trial however the case against
him soon fell apart after two witnesses
were killed and
so the charges were dropped in 1946 veto
genovese was again a free man and he
wanted to reclaim
power of the luciano crime family except
that frank costello was now at the head
of the table and unsurprisingly he was
not interested in giving up his seat the
first episode in this new power struggle
occurred in december of that same year
there were a lot of important matters to
discuss
and since luchado was unable to return
to america he organized a meeting in
cuba
urbana conference as it came to be known
was a landmark moment in the history of
the american mafia where all the
important mobsters got together to
discuss
the most pressing issues of the day last
time they did this they ended the castle
moraisi war and formed the commission
allegedly genovese arrived a few days
early in cuba and had a private meeting
with luciano who had become aware
of his former underboss's growing
ambitions at this point genovese
was not openly feuding with costello and
luciano yet since he was not strong
enough to win
however he did have altercations over
rackets and territory with
albert anastasia and suggested to
luciano that maybe it was time to get
rid of anastasia as
he was too violent and unstable hit a
point also known as the mad hatter and
lord high executioner albert anastasia
was one of the most ruthless mobsters in
the mafia's history and
definitely a future target for
biographics by the way however that is
not why genovese wants him out of the
picture
anastasia was the former boss of murder
incorporated
and now is the head of his own crime
family he was loyal to luciano and a
powerful ally to costello back in the
states genevazi's
second point was far less subtle he
suggested that maybe it was time for
luciano to retire since
he could not return to america and to
cede control of the family to him
unsurprisingly luciano did not take well
to either suggestion during the meeting
itself he reaffirmed his position as
chairman of the commission and
thus the de facto leader of the mafia
and then he also made genebasia and
anastasia shake hands in front of the
other mobsters to
prevent another castel-moraisi war as
for costello he was right there next to
luciano and
would continue to serve as the acting
boss of the family back in new york
unfortunately for luciano the american
government found out that he had left
italy and traveled to cuba he blamed
genovese for this believing that he had
tipped off the authorities according to
his later biography luciano had vito
come to his room where
he gave him a beating and broke three of
his ribs leaving him bedridden for three
days
facing intense pressure from the
american government cuba eventually
arrested and deported luciano back to
italy
where he spent the remainder of his life
under much stricter surveillance the
next time he traveled back to the united
states
he did so in a coffin
[Music]
although lucky luciano was still in
charge the fact that he was in italy
severely damaged his influence it was
inevitable that other mobsters would
start to feel like his time was over and
genovese wasn't the only one in his
situation his most powerful ally was
carlo gambino who was gunning for
anastasia's position while vito wanted
what costello had
to make matters even worse in 1951
castello also had to contend with the
first major investigation into the
american mafia
officially it had a very long and boring
name but everyone referred to it
as the key for the hearings after
tennessee senator estes kieva this was
the man who chaired the committee and
helped launch the investigation over 600
witnesses were called to testify
including prominent members such as
mayor lansky micky gohan and tony agardo
although the picture of frank costello
before the committee became the most
famous iconic image associated with the
hearings of course people didn't have to
settle for just images as most of the
hearings were televised and gained some
of the highest ratings ever
giving most of the american public their
first exposure to the mafia although the
investigation obviously did not stop the
mob it led to several reforms and the
creation of multiple federal and state
squads that
dealt with organized crime it also got
the fbi to finally admit that the
national crimes indicate existed but
overall after the hearings were over the
mob was still
as powerful as ever frank costello was
among the most affected by the kefoba
hearings he refused to answer many
questions during his testimony at one
point walked out on the committee i'm
not going to answer another question
you just says i'm not under arrest and
i'm going to walk out he was charged
with contempt and sentenced to 18 months
in prison then he had another five years
out of a tax evasion and
although he was sometimes out on bail or
pending an appeal costello spent
most of the first half of the 50s behind
bars
costello's incarceration presented a
great opportunity for veto genovese to
try and force his way back to the top of
the family he wouldn't make a direct
move against costello that would have
been
to brazen but he started out by dealing
with his allies
first was willie moretti costello's
underboss and the man who controlled a
lot of the family's muscle
moretti suffered from the advanced
stages of syphilis and this greatly
impacted his mental faculties he had a
tendency to ramble incoherently and
genovese persuaded the other bosses that
this turned him into a liability he
proclaimed maretti's sentence to be
a mercy killing although it certainly
did not look like one on october 4th
1951 moretti was having lunch at joe's
elbow room in new
jersey with four associates unidentified
gunman entered the restaurant and shot
moretti repeatedly in the head and face
before
making their escape maretti's death was
a heavy blow for costello and
things got worse in 1956 when another
key ally joe adonis voluntarily moved
back to italy instead of serving a
lengthy jail sentence in america when
costello was out of prison he found his
position considerably weakened it was
weak enough that genovese decided it was
finally time to take him out on may 2nd
1957 costello was headed towards his
apartment in manhattan he'd entered the
lobby unaware that a large stranger was
waiting for him behind a pillar costello
heard somebody shout this is for you
frank he turned around just as the
stranger pulled the trigger
and shot him in the head before making
his getaway in a black cadillac
his would-be assassin did not realize
that the bullet only grazed his head and
just left a superficial wound frank
costello was still alive for now
but he realized that if it happened once
it was going to happen again just a few
months later there was also a hit on his
final ally albert anastasia except
this one was far more successful on
october 25th the mad hatter was at the
barber shop of
the park sheraton hotel relaxing in the
barber's chair with a towel on his head
two gunmen entered the shop
and shot him ten times afterwards carlo
gambino became the new head of the
family renaming it after himself
the writing was on the wall for costello
his allies were dead luciano could only
watch what happened helplessly from
italy he had lost the war with vito
genobesie it was just a matter
of how he would finish it his saving
grace was the fact that he stuck to the
strict code of silence or a murder and
refused to cooperate with the police
ostensibly his shooter was identified as
vincent the chin gigante an enforcer and
future family boss who was obviously
working on genovese's orders however in
court costello refused to identify him
saying that
he'd never seen that man in his life
giganto was acquitted and genevase
became the new head of the family
renaming it after him and
adopting the moniker don vito however
for keeping quiet costello was allowed
to retire even
keeping his legitimate businesses and
some of his gambling operations as a
source of revenue
in the movies this would surely be a
fake out allowing costello to
let his guard down before another hit
takes him out permanently
but that didn't happen in real life once
he agreed to don vito's terms there were
no more attempts on his life and
ultimately genevasi
did not get to enjoy his new position of
power for long although
well that's a story for another day even
though he wasn't a boss anymore costello
still had plenty of respect and
influence he was the prime minister
after all
and all the connections and favors he
collected over a lifetime still proved
to be useful
to the other mobsters who turned to him
for assistance costello remained
involved with the mafia one way or
another until his death which came
following a heart attack in 1973
at the age of 82. so i really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button below don't forget to
subscribe also please do
check out our fantastic sponsor ground
news link below
and thank you for watching